I got off the bus from secaucus and my
cousin Gina moved to burbank and we're
all jealous apart and i was so tired and
sit on my ass for three days and she's
like you need to change we're going out
tonight and I'm like okay and she throws
these vinyl pants to me that I got
annoying they got tiger stripes on him
they're crazy I never want anything like
this in my life and I'm like I got a
change in the cottage she's like
changing the clown we're going to the
Sunset Strip baby rainbow room and I'm
like okay the rainbow room sounds like
this uppity jazz club we're movie stars
hang out and I don't know what to expect
so we go down now we park now Gina is a
host of his public access music show
called metal memoirs they don't pay or
anything but she interviews bands and
she gets a lot of free records and a lot
of free music so constant tickets things
like that it's worth it so she's
determined to get an interview tonight
and for some reason I got to be the
cameraman so she hands with this
gigantic camera I never operated before
my life and she's like you got to fill
me I'm going to get an interview tonight
because there's tons of things people in
that I know there's going to be a rock
star I need to get one for my shop so we
get in line the line is around the block
it takes us an hour to get close to the
front door and I'm like Geno I just want
to go to sleep I'm about to pass out and
hot these vinyl pants of squeezing the
life out of me it's time to go and just
some about to pass out I hear this voice
its deep its British and I turn around
and there's a scraggly black hair and
his leather pants and his mustache and
these two gigantic moles on his face and
I'm like that's lemme that's ace of
spades one levy you girls want to go to
the VIP road with me and I'm like um
Gina just like
yes and he grabs us by hand and drags us
into the club in front of all these
people and let me let me prove with
lumbee and we go inside and as a sea of
people and the most beautiful people
I've ever seen my life the guys they've
got more Rouge than my Aunt Rose the
girls they look like Olivia newton-john
with big hair and leather pants and big
tits like high-class strippers these
girls boy so beautiful I didn't to do
with myself I almost don't notice to my
left at a table two girls on each are
two girls under the table you know what
I'm sayin big spiky black hair and eye
line at the size of Texas and he's so
hot and doing lines on the table and
doing shots with all his friends and all
I want to do is be a part of it and let
me it's like Oh what girls go upstairs
and meet me later I got business to
attend to and I'm like up okay and
Gina's like come on we're going to the
IP if it takes us all night so he
ditched us it's okay she takes me by the
hand we go upstairs and I'm like VIP if
this is the regular room what the hell
does VIP look like we go upstairs and
there's a concept plan there's a band on
stage is this little guy curly black
hair everybody's got black hair and he's
like up to my chin short and I'm like
this crate oh wait a minute wait a
minute Gina that's do rainbow in the
dark dia on stage oh my god I never seen
to you before in my life here he is ten
feet the thread of me in this tiny
little room playing a concert just for
me and Gina and a few other people I
just so special and Gina just waits by
the stage page League rocking out and
I'm just like karen is gigantic
really and digo comes off the stage just
as he's done and he gives me a big hug
like he's known his whole life and I'm
like oh my god I was such McDonald of
you deal would you mind um it's my
friend Gina would interview for her show
and he's like no problem this guy's nice
time in my life he's all scary and mean
and singing on TV and everybody's like
afraid of them but he's so nice and Gina
it's just on fire interviewing him my
hands are shaking the cameras about to
fall to the ground it's so heavy but do
man he's the best and it was just such a
special time I'm like this is the
greatest moment in my life I mean I'm
waiting tables and see carcass at
Finley's province the shittiest life and
I come here and I'm hanging out with do
and let me and Nikki Sixx and I feeling
like the coolest girl in the world you
know the day it died was the day smells
like teen spirit went to number one on
the radio I remember that day and the
side to fade away it just gave me such
comfort that we had these memories and
you know someone was never left and
that's okay you just got to go down to
the Sunset Strip and there's still
people around spandex lipstick root big
hail it's still there I have some lyrics
i want to read from deal metal will
never die feel the danger see the glory
hear the thunder of a heavy metal it
will take you hypnotize you raise your
fist with the rebel yell I am Medellin
never die we are meadow and will never
die I will crank you up you can't bring
me down I will make you high metal will
never die nothing evil nothing's sacred
just a power that's been created there
to take you possess you shout it out
with a voice from hell I own metal and
I'll never die we are metal and will
never die masterpiece